à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sécheresse maladie incendie notre forêt
souffrent les arbres couvre un tiers de
la planète est aussi un tiers de la
france ils sont indispensables à notre
survie mais comment les protéger les
soigner et aussi préparer la forêt de
demain
[Musique]
mais
voilà chaîne qui est mourant
il a encore quelques feuilles mais il va
mourir très rapidement donc je prends
son diamètre donc porte classe de
diamètre c'est un 35
jeux le pointe
donc avec un outil très traditionnelle
et
je lui mets un trait de peinture pour
que le bûcheron qui viendra la battre le
voit de loin
abattre un arbre condamné c'est toujours
un crève coeur pour alexis achète et
lorsqu'il lève la tête si pour compter
les victimes
derrière moi on a un être
dont le feuillage est très déficitaire
les corses est tombé donc son pronostic
vital il est engagé ces questions de
compte à rebours il va mourir c'est
certain
nous ont fait que passer par rapport aux
arbres c'est mon arrière grand père quoi
mais bon il est mort on arrête grand
père cet arbre il est vivant enfin il en
train de mourir ils en phase terminale
alexis parcours la forêt de vierzon
depuis 30 ans et chaque jour il prend la
mesure des ravages de la sécheresse
s'imaginait qu'ici il y a une trentaine
d'années on ne voyait pas le ciel le
couvert forestier était complètement
fermée aujourd'hui on assez énorme
clairière qui se sont créés et ses
arbres morts
donc on a un phénomène
qui progresse par à-coups de
dépérissement et troué qui
s'agrandissent
depuis cette année lohan f quantifie le
dépérissement des forêts à partir de 20
% d'arbres morts un plan de gestion de
crise et déclencher
agir c'est aussi prévoir nous sommes
près de montargis à l'inra l'institut de
recherche agronomique et
environnementale
sur le site de l'arboretum des bars
ici les scientifiques travaillent à
partir des modèles du giec et de météo
france pour prévoir l'évolution de la
forêt en fonction du réchauffement
climatique et pour le chêne sessile
majoritaire dans la région
l'avenir est sombre
dès 2050 son aire de répartition et son
erreur favorable se sont fortement
réduites et quand 2070 donc on voit que
ces mêmes défavorable à sa croissance et
à sa survie dans la dans la plupart de
la france au niveau du changement
climatique c'est pas il n'y a pas
matière à réjouissance
il faut il faut agir et j'invite
agir c'est le dispositif au petit mix
mise en place par les chercheurs de
l'inra et pour étudier l'impact du
changement climatique sur les arbres
dans la forêt d'orléans la plus grande
forêt publique de france
une délégation de sylviculteurs normand
a fait le voyage pour voir cette
expérience unique en europe destiné à
les aider dans leur choix de plantation
la forêt d'orléans qui compte cinquante
mille hectares elle évapore par jour les
1.5 million de mètres cubes d'eau en
saison estivale il ya un jour ensoleillé
comme aujourd'hui et ce volume d'eau
correspond à 500 volume de 500 piscine
olympique
nathalie camboulives ski la responsable
du projet emmène ses visiteurs dans
l'une des trente trois parcelles
d'observation disséminés en forêt
d'orléans ici par exemple une fosse a
été creusée pour mesurer l'eau en sous
sol
on pensait déjà être très bas est très
très sec avec des niveaux d'eau tour de
30 % d'humidité dans l'argile alors
qu'on a à terme d'arriver à plus bas
encore les années d'après est encore
plus évident que le bloc là c'est de
plus en plus dur est de plus en plus
difficile aux racines à percer à travers
et aller chercher l'eau plus profonde
plus en profondeur
la forêt privée représente 80% des
forêts françaises chez ses propriétaires
l'inquiétude grandit d'autant que la
gestion des arbres est aussi pour eux
une source de revenus jamais vu une
situation pareille à les pincer le passé
on peut disparaître on a fait des
kilomètres dans la forêt il ya un vrai
cataclysme dans cette forêt
concrètement on peut avoir des
peuplements qui peuvent disparaître dans
dix quinze ans si si on fait des bêtises
si on met de mauvaise essence etc qui
sont pas adaptées aux sols etc
certains propriétaires privés ont
préféré anticiper d'éventuelles
catastrophes climatiques
ah oui là vous avez des bonnes ou glace
geoffroy de moncuit possède 160 hectares
de forêt en sologne il y à 7 ans il a
planté un millier de chêne pubescent une
espèce méridionale en remplacement du
traditionnel chêne sessile
là j'ai deux feuilles d'une feuille de
chêne pubescent
probablement du sud de la france
d'origine du sud de la france et est une
petite feuille très très découpées alors
qu'ici vous avez la feuille du chaînes
traditionnelles de notre région le chêne
sessile qui est beaucoup plus large et
beaucoup moins échancré la différence
c'est que lui pousse bien dans les
régions méditerranéennes
c'est à dire on sait donc qu'il se
contente de dunes d'humilité beaucoup
plus irrégulières et surtout beaucoup
plus saisonnière alors que le chêne
sessile il est habitué à avoir une
hygrométrie plus régulière tout au tout
au long de l'année ce chêne du sud
sera-t-il le nouveau roi des forêts
tempérées réponse dans un siècle et demi
en attendant les jeunes pousses sont
couvés par leurs propriétaires on a cru
qu'il était mort mais les biens partent
et je laisse les deux temps qu'ils se
gênent pas c'est l'avenir
non là c'est c'est pas trop mal mais pas
trop mal
les chênes pubescents ne sont pas les
seuls essences méditerranéennes planté
par le sylviculteur ces jeunes cèdre de
l'atlas ont une quinzaine d'années et
semble se plaire dans la terre pauvre de
sologne
j'ai coupé les branches je continue à
les couper progressivement vous voyez
d'ailleurs très bien là où il y avait
une branche et dans votre prend tout
quarante ans on le verra même pu c'est
comme ça qu'on a un beau bois sans ne un
cèdre qui devra néanmoins trouver des
débouchés à la commercialisation vous
vous fait faire une maison
traditionnellement elle est en brique ou
en parpaings maintenant de plus en plus
votre maison elle est en bois si vous le
voulez c'est une nouvelle utilisation du
bois qui n'existait pas il ya une
vingtaine d'années et qui est en pleine
en plein développement maintenant je
pense que le sel peut rentrer également
dans cette utilisait cette nouvelle
utilisation de construction de maison je
pense pas qu'on s'en tirera simplement
avec quelques exemples à droite à gauche
il faut transformer chaque sylviculteurs
en un acteur du renouvellement de la
forêt c'est ça tout l'enjeu pour pour
l'avenir ce que n'oubliez pas que la
forêt privée française c'est quand même
12 plus de 12 millions d'hectares donc
il ya du travail sur devant nous
[Musique]
nous retrouvons nathalie et camille les
scientifiques de l'inra est au coeur de
la forêt d'orléans dans une des
parcelles dédiées aux projets au petit
mix cette étude exceptionnel par son
ampleur croiser plusieurs critères comme
la densité des arbres les mélange
d'espèces ou la présence de grands
animaux pour connaître leurs
conséquences sur le fonctionnement de la
forêt
c'est des arbres qui vivent longtemps
jusqu'à 180 ans pour les chaînes donc ce
qu'on veut voir c'est aussi leur
évolution
comment ils réagissent à des événements
climatiques ponctuelles pour l'instant
mais peut-être récurrent qui vont se
répéter plusieurs années de suite dans 5
ou 10 ans neuf mille deux cents arbres
sont cartographiés connecter plusieurs
centaines par parcelle
je télécharge des données là que nos
ordinateurs on va dire terrain qui sont
reliés à différents capteurs
environnementaux
aujourd'hui c'est à peu près 800
capteurs qui travaillent qui enregistre
15 milles donnés par jour en quelle
année ça fait 5 millions cinq cent mille
2 n'est donc qu'au récupère et qui nous
permettent à près de de comparer les
différents peuplement ou différente si
vie culture qu'on peut avoir sur le sol
dispositif optimiste
pour terminer nos scientifiques lâchent
leur ordinateur au profit de ceux
lance-pierre géant qui permet de
récolter des feuilles ou des aiguilles
au sommet des arbres
[Musique]
camille a ramené des feuilles de chêne
pour mesurer en laboratoire la réaction
de l'arbre en période de sécheresse
en train de mesurer le stress hydrique
eu des arbres donc bah c'est lié mon
corps à haute température aux canicules
aux sécheresses et plus on a des délais
une fin d'événement successifs comme ça
où l'on plus valable et déstresser et
donc une des façons de mesurer c'est de
mettre des feuilles sous pression et
d'observer la sortie de la scène
on a mesuré donc avec cet appareil la
dépression allant jusqu'à 25 bars alors
que sur un arbre moins stressés on est
soudés autour de 5 batz
démarré il y a 6 ans cette étude
permettra de tirer des conclusions
seulement dans quelques dizaines
d'années à l'échelle de la vie d'un
arbre
en forêt de vierzon alexis achète le
responsable de l'oim nef se désole tous
les jours des ravages de la sécheresse
[Musique]
on n'a pas appris la bonne mesure du
phénomène globalement
ce qui me fait dire ça c'est que si on
l'apprenait on changerait de façon de
vivre en fait le débat il est plutôt à
ce niveau là donc vivre d'une façon plus
ancré dans la nature alors
qu'aujourd'hui l'humanité elle vit
majoritairement en ville elle est coupée
de la nature et ça c'est dommage il ya
peut-être un mouvement qui s'amorce en
ce sens ça va devenir probablement une
nécessité
dans un siècle nos forêts auront sans
doute radicalement changé d'autres
variétés d'arbres les peupleront plus
adaptée aux changements climatiques en
attendant il faudra composer avec un
dépérissement qui va s'accentuer au fil
des ans
[Musique]